imagine is already sighs what my friend
this is our budget
imagine 8,000 people send your head
absolutely crushed
[Applause]
realistically creature was [__]
what's going on everyone it's the trove
Geordie but again and it's time for my
honest opinion ksi versus jor-el our
years of all being asked in foreign what
is the true Geordie really think I was
right in the middle of it I [__] know
fighting I've got mixed emotions about
this and I really really [__] do this
could end up being one of the best
things we've ever seen on YouTube or one
of the worst and if it's done right
it'll be great if it's done wrong it'll
be terrible
which is why I need to be heavily
involved in paid well for my services of
course in all seriousness though I'll
really just what I care about YouTube I
don't want people to be looking on the
Facebook's like this is embarrassing or
whatever and then you've got the other
side of people who are like right into
this or modern jjr jort and not each
other out so I'm gonna try and really
break this down forward today and then
one of the main questions are being
asked I'm gonna answer right now was it
all fake on stage was it all set up with
me included and new and exactly what's
gonna happen
WWH style and honestly yes yes it was
nor wasn't I [__] got you honestly
beforehand and this is exactly what
happened I said to the lads we're gonna
do a press conference I'm gonna ask you
some questions when I think it's time to
wrap this [__] up we're gonna do a
face-off that is it
I had a feeling it was gonna kick off
because earlier in the day it newly did
the lads hadn't thrown punches at that
point but it just seemed playful but the
more people are watching and the more
you try now do each other
playfulness contain nasty Jenna what I'm
saying and with two egos involved like
JJ and Joe Walton I don't want to be
undone do you know what I mean so
they're gonna push each other and push
each other in and to the point where it
can't get out of hand so I thought me
some I'll tell the security gods alright
if it kicks off lads grub them for
[__] sake I'll grab one you scrub the
other there's loads of them I'm still
the void don't worry about it there's a
little disguise I was like look I just
want to make sure the lads don't get
hurt we'll have a bit of fun and that's
an order
no no cuz I was the only security guard
he was able to do his [__] job and
I'm not even a security guard
so a lot of people are wanting to know
generally do I think this beef is real
and honestly it definitely didn't start
over sorry let's be honest these lads go
way back Joe was a lot of his career
- JJ they go on holiday together they're
good mates generally I mean I don't
think it started out as real but when
lads challenge each other it will fight
on Instagram that is is a challenge and
we are we've got egos we want to be the
Alpha you don't want to be outdone so it
gets playful and then say all right
we'll do this press conference next
thing you know they're on stage
thousands of people are watching you
wanting to come out on top you're
pushing each other's buttons you're
trying to get in each other's head and
whether or not they really love or hate
each other or whatever the [__] do you
want to know what Israel getting punched
in your [__] face in front of
thousands of people and millions
watching at home and that is gonna
happen if what if what they say it is to
be believed they're gonna [__] do
that
so whether they each other or who gives
a [__] because these lads could end up
getting [__] one of them big time
could be [__] humiliated if this goes
down I've got a [__] hope that
doesn't happen I really hope that does
not by the way I mean is this even a
good idea from a business side of things
this is [__] genius make no mistake
about it people were bored of drama
along comes discs records people now get
our bit bored of that it's like extreme
enough along comes YouTube [__] a
boxing the problem with that is who'd
you get to [__] do it how many people
are actually got the balls to get in
there and swing and if you've got the
balls to do it how many people are
actually fit enough enable enough and
athletic enough to pull it off and
actually got a big enough audience who's
going to turn up to event and actually
give a [__]
ladies and gentlemen I give you ksi vs.
Joella pretty much the only fight that
actually makes sense
and one of them that actually could be
gripping enough that people are gonna
care to that similar size both Oregon is
[__] Eagle got the Alpha above them both
train fit strong lads and can bring and
can fill a [__] arena do you know
what I mean it makes sense you know this
is gonna make a [__] ton of money they
could sell the I pay ticket do you know
the closer you sit the higher the
[__] price you know get me and
they're doing a bit of culinary I'll do
a [__] meet-and-greet this could be
genius and mainstream media
this is going to sell more tickets than
any normal box an event barf up an
undelete just you and people like that
a lot of below that you look this is
gonna be big news so mainstream media
are going to get involved
this could really elevate jaw and JJ
must I think this is [__] great idea
me worry is if it isn't taken seriously
by the lads involved namely Joe and JJ
and the production value isn't as good
as what it could be it could end up
making YouTube look amateur make people
laugh at it the way they do with some of
the music do you know what I mean and I
want this to be a success so I'm just
worried that the lads might not take it
seriously enough I'm not seeing I don't
think they will take it seriously enough
because George AJ take on everything
seriously and tell by the success that
they've had but in order for this to be
cluster success to the naysayers and the
people who are ridicule this and call it
a job these lads are gonna have to get
in there and look like they've trained
in boxing look like they know how to
throw a punch and give it a good [__]
go children I mean and only then will it
be seen as a success by everyone or
almost everyone I know a lot of years I
couldn't want us to give a prediction
already and I kind of give a final
prediction now but I feel like I can
give you a bit of insight cos I talked
to Botha lads before the press
conference JJ told us his way Joe told
us his way and I'm not if I'm not
mistaken I think JJ is actually to Storn
heavier than Joe and anyone who knows
about fighting in general they've got
weight classes for a [__] reason that
that is a massive and GJ is not fat he's
in the shape of his life as its jaw that
to stone it's just general borne density
and you're gonna expect JJ to be a bit
more powerful in the punching department
than what Joe is however I've got to
give credit to jaw Punk for pound for 11
stone or whatever the [__] is that kid
is very strong for his size I'm not even
just saying it man I'm being deadly sees
he is really strong for his size so he
might surprise people and be stronger
than JJ because of all the years of
training but I've just got to look at JJ
and think if he hits jaw and Joe hits
him at the same time JJ will have a more
powerful punch that's my opinion
however Joe might be quicker he's
trained a long time he's light
and speed kills in a [__] boxing ring
and also fitter I would assume because
he's been traded for years
however jaw does have a knee injury and
that may affect this called you on the
run up and if change it can take
advantage of that and do a [__] Turner
runnin we might say JJ be the fair on
the rink it's very hard to tell one
thing that I think we can all have an
opinion on is the mindset the
personality will watch these lads for
years who's got more fight in them who's
taking this more seriously and before
the fight I can tell you for a [__]
fact
Joe was taking it more seriously I spoke
to JJ and he seemed well chilled out
well laid-back Gemma just gonna get in
the ring no problem Joe asked him you
know this could gun this could gone bad
you know I mean if you're not wearing
head gear and that because I talked
about not wearing head gear I'm like one
of yours is probably gonna get knocked
out when I know there's only one person
getting knocked out in this vapor I and
that's him and H it's being deadly
[__] serious and he stole bitter words
I'm like [__] me Easy's he [__] means
it whereas GG was saw children and I
think it showed on stage because JJ was
very quick with it very funny more
relaxed whereas Joel was all wound up
and normally they'd be on a par four but
Aaron taking the piss of each other was
JJ was getting the better of it to be
honest that's why I could sure cuz it
was getting a bit repetitive but when
Jill came back with that line at the end
and all erupted it GG showed that he was
Kim and I was a fair blaze up cuz I'm
splitting them up I've got one hand on
jaw I'm thinking someone will grab
changing it it's fine someone so look at
what it's trying what someone gotta get
a hold of this country minute cuz I'm
gonna end up just being a [__]
sandwich yeah and I know a lot of women
out there would love to be made happy
these [__] fangirls but honestly
JJ's kicking the [__] was some kid on
the floor My Fair Play haha so after
that JJ makes a video and I can say that
it's turned he is much more serious now
after that than what he was before hand
and now they're both on a par they both
want to rip each other's head off I
don't think this hatred yeah it's just
competition it's the alpha male [__] so
who's gonna win this fight I can tell
you right now whoever takes it more
seriously
who
is getting up in the morning train and
gone for runs getting the cardio in
making sure they get in the ring do some
sparring hitting the bag trainer getting
comfortable with being hit and throwing
punches back and not getting flustered
by it that's the person who's gonna
[__] win this fight without a doubt
and I'm worried to be honest with you
because I don't want to say either lad
get embarrassed and humiliated and I
know that's the Bloods faced and a lot
of people is what's gonna make them tune
in but I watch fighting all the time man
I don't need to see too many pawns
getting [__] knocked out you know
what I mean I don't there's a promise I
would rather this didn't happen in a way
because if one of these lads gets
knocked out in front of the entire
[__] world and they could up and
they'll never live it down man that
YouTube us they're not going to be able
to get in there and I'd have a few more
fights and make a run for the title this
is it it's one and done practically so
if you do that and you get Farland
absolutely smoked in front of the world
every time you trio every video every
social media post you ever put out the
full stop on the end of your last
sentence is gonna be a gif of you lying
there asleep on the [__] floor and I
don't want that for my pulse-jet on I'm
in this report visitor that doesn't want
this fight to happen so the ideal
scenario would be the however long
however many rounds it is it's a wall
they both get a shot SID
they both take a few they both look good
they put on a good show they do YouTube
proud and it's a split decision or a
draw Rocky Balboa Apollo Creed style
that's my well I don't want is a Jersey
Aldo thirteen second moment where one of
these lads gets 13 seconds written after
every [__] tweet like Josie Aldo does
these days but we're going to see what's
going to happen let us know what you
think about everything in the comments
below who do you think is gonna win this
[__] fight like the video subscribe
thanks for watching and I'll see us
later
[Music]